mediaset i ragazzi dove sono video sono
fa vj e ricominciare ragazzi volevo
farmi da piccolissima premessa
velocissima questo gioco che state per
vedere in teoria non lo volevo mettere
proprio non volevo caricare questo video
non volevo metterlo poi c'è questo in
assoluto gioco più trash che io abbia
mai fatto in tutta la mia vita
giuro che dovete capire che cosa ho
passato per un'ora di fila dovete
capirlo ragazzi dovuto dovuto carica ho
dovuto ho dovuto luca al maestro è stato
è stato tra mi lascia video tutto rosso
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti avessero
video sono fa vj oggi stiamo su allora
non so che cosa state per vedere non ne
ho idea ho visto due screen in croce di
questa roba visto la roba più strana
nella mia vita c'è la lingua italiana e
la cosa mi sorprende abbastanza out
ovata source presenza che ho messo
italiano ovviamente in inglese la sesta
età porta il povero vecchio buffone
pantofolaio vi rendete conto delle
stronze a questo se fu mancati lato
ganja ma un tipo cinque minuti fa lo sa
cazzo sta succedendo
oh mio dio con uno sperma sono uno
spermatozoo ok ma sei serio stai attento
cazzone canzone prima adesso è uscito
già fatemi capire solo la gente
fertilizza devo andare a
seminare luogo che bello che cosa ha
spinto il creatore di questo gioco a
creare questa cosa voglio delle risposte
grazie ho sempre sognato di impersonare
uno spermatozoo l'ho fatta ho vinto una
volta tipo 20 anni fa ce la posso fare
anche adesso ci avevo io la precedenza
stregua le rispetta al semaforo cogliano
ticketing
non sapevo che nell'utero ci fossero
queste cose macchinose per nascere più
hard burn 1948 non ha veramente se nel
95 prova una linea di massima sono già
diventato così e continuo e continua a
navigare agli tra spazio un occhio ma
che cazzo gioco minima idea di come ha
fatto lutero femminile è una roba che
cazzo guardi a casa mi fissano sono nudo
ai miei fisso a ma che cazzo che sono io
ci sono tanto ero più bello da piccolo
non sono anche il pen questo ci fanno
fiocchi come si parla madonna che è
stata lodata dai creatori di sorge
completamente che i bambini all in one
luce siano quindi non è non è che i
ragazzi non è così non è così ve lo dico
io
sì sto viaggiando nell'utero da 45
minuti ininterrotti ma che palle sto
cazzo preferisco morire e fatemi
sbattere ecco taglia il cordone vecchio
fatta su per nascere mia cagato credo
che la mia abbia appena cagato atto 1
ottobre 1950 un'infanzia ciò tipo tre
anni ce la posso fare sono gas sono
sempre più nudo una roba tv una svastica
che cazzo di gioco è ricche ma basta
basta bisogna alzato p.zza madonna manco
mastro lindo e così muscoloso il gioco
di merda e qui sono morto niente mammina
niente papino oddio spiaggia buongiorno
stato basta vi prego mio cosa cos'è è
sorto un bidone dell'immondizia si è
messo a correre
oh mio dio delle svolte in craxi fece un
wolverine pupazzo scott hodes no non mi
toccare se il brutto che non sapevano
cosa mente li sto gioco allora mettiamo
più
prima c'era un pupazzo così adesso
mettiamo più pupazzi più svastiche mi
sono sbagliato si può stare calmi sì sì
signori da wolverine convinto io ho
vinto io 1955 vada a scuola sempre nudo
perché non ai vestiti non posso
permettermi vestiti palmer in faccia
sulla porta va bene che sei bello nudo e
pelato chi è il tuo parrucchiere
mastrolindo sono così posso fare
qualcosa di diverso da prima no è tutto
così sto gioco del cazzo hai want you to
smaila want you to fuck your mother ha
un preciso significato sto gioco sulla
guerra alle cose
questo iter più figo però
1961 adolescenza ovviamente nudi non ho
preso dello sperma in faccia ai ragazzi
adolescenza vedo tutto luminoso vedo
funghi ovunque corro nudo chiari sintomi
di ganja overuse e il proprio check
complimenti amico mio hai capito tutta
la vita soprattutto i peli pubici che
stanno uscendo dal terreno non ho capito
che cosa sono altro sperma cercando di
trovare senza la mia vita dopo quel
cos'è un mare di piscio non è che
grafica della famiglia
battlefield please lì sono chiaramente
capelli oppure pelli pubblici non lo so
è finito
ti ringrazio gesù proprio ti ringrazio e
poi l'amante luce mente come una caldaia
ma no io non smetto
ti prego ha un pene ha un pene ma è una
donna cazzo è il culo di prima non ce
l'avevano uomo col rovescio questo mondo
ma trangoni ha le tette non puoi avere
un pene è le terre cazzo sei brutto
ragazzi io non mi rifiuto rilasciato 16
anni dietro di te ma mica meglio perché
tu vuoi o mio dio mio di nascondino lo
schifo che cazzo cosa ti tocchi adesso
in avanti su questo video dovete sfogare
i vostri istinti sessuali su questo
preciso non su altro perché questa è
l'apoteosi del sesso mi vendo a vomitare
l'anima e ai ragazzi
penso che i porno afro francesi siano
meglio di questa cosa ci muoviamo
dobbiamo stare qui tutta la cazzo di
vita per vedere in ogni non è bello
vedere il suo pene che sbatte una parte
all'altra
lo assicura possiamo finire questa purga
pedopornografica che sta andando avanti
da mezz'ora che vi giuro che sto per
vomitare tutta la cena di natale scorso
da un pene è finito è finito grazie a
dio è stata la differenza fin brutta la
mia vita ma vabbè sono un soldato
minchia spero che muoio ti giuro guarda
ascoltami zio in guerra in teoria
windows e gli elmetti c'è un po di roba
ce l'hai addosso 6 luglio oppure in
guerra cazzo le bombe le demo schiva le
bombe ma vai vai che faccio tipo matrix
spara spara spara che ci provato a
sparare più
più grosso che ai più grosso del pene di
prima che ci vuole molto almeno salta
maledizione sì lo scopo nel culo per
metà perché i veri uomini combattono
nuti nudi
proprio come mamma li ha fatti arrivando
al mio anno di nascita ragazzi valentia
vedrete un bambino nudo
cos'e successo o mio zio una siringa
quasi nel culo sul rene ci possiamo
lavorare per farmi capire una cosa sono
andato giù di droghe perché adesso ce
l'ha nel culo perfetto questo è un gioco
del 2015 si commenta da solo ragazzi non
ce la posso fare
allora se il prossimo non è una cosa
normale io spendo è finito ti prego 2011
o dance dance sarà tectonic frega un
cazzo molto meno trash di tutto il resto
che sta succedendo cos'è ma siamo in
discoteca in matrix aprile 2013 fi che
questo gioco sia stato fatto nel 2013
che finisce qui c'è illumina i nominati
per non capirlo subito cazzo della prima
cosa mi doveva venire in mente che
perché c'è britney spears perché c'è
presidi spia luglio 2019 2000 ancora van
dell'utero cioè 80 anni si possono
scaricare le canzoni metto essere sul
telefono giusto deprimerci la giornata
ancora di più se stessa porta al povero
pantofolaio no
addio crepa ti prego dio buzzati judo
arrivare fin laggiù col bastone con
madonna tolin filone cos'è il mio dio
sono andato in botta ma perché sei tutto
distorto mio dio allora devi andare
dritte e questo che succede quando bevi
beckham vecchia mi beckham i beckham i
no finita la musica quindi muoio muoio
muori
muorinho morire atroce me basta basta
basta cazzo si è fermato s'è fermato
timore smette di pal parti la chiappa
sinistra morirei posso volare col
bastone dobbiamo fare anche tutta la al
di là che un po lunga al di là ai
ragazzi quindi se magari string chiamo
stringiamo questa cosa grazie string
chiamo bene e sono diventato un vecchio
rumble basta muori ti prego dai dai
[Musica]
ai crepa porca put crepa è andato giù e
andato giu e morto è morto è morto è
morto che non torna è tornato io sto
svenendo re che perché c'è un pi greco
cos'è successo superato il pi greco
morte i cento anni di storia in blood
and honey mi chiedono investivo con un
tir piuttosto vi lasci in chiusura
ragazzi vi lascio in chiusura sulle mani
perché so che ci avete questa sentita il
ritmo nelle vene sulle mani su tutti
spiegatemi che cosa ci fa ok sono andati
sono tornato bambino
sì sì sì sì se tutto da capo tutta la
carta verde un sex magik santo sono mai
stato contento il mario valente
t'ammazzo la famiglia non sono veramente
mai stato così contento di dei titoli di
coda lì a quest'uomo non so chi è ma se
ha fatto il gioco
gli faccio nel male fisico oltre al
gioco mio dio
oltre al gioco non bere non bere che
passion escono se merde come giochi non
bere concluso quindi lo sparo vi sia
piaciuto l'ho adorato personalmente ai
vi sia piaciuto come se lo strumento
milan capace di facebook e come noi
video tratte descrizione se questi
dischetti decimi di anno prossimo video
e la ragazza kipps mailing tua sorella